هذا المبنى ليس جديدا لكن الحضور
قد سجلوا سابقا اشكركم مره اخرى واشكر
كافه الناس الذين يقفون في الخارج
والى الرئيس الى الرئيس تشيفر الذي لطالما
عكف على عقد هذه المؤتمرات في مؤتمرات
الحزب الوطني في ولايه جورجيا على مر
السنوات الماضيه فلنجعل امريكا عظيمه
مجددا
لا يا له من قول عظيم وسوف ينضم الينا
ايضا رئيس
عضو الكونجرس هيدسن
سوف
نتوجه الى ولايتهم بعد بضع دقائق والى
نورث كارولاينا وهذا امر عظيم لكن تهانينا
ريتشارد على العمل الجيد بالاضافه الى ذلك
فانني فخور
لتلقي اعتماد بعض
الوطنيين في جورجيا
شخص عظيم
واندرو كلايد ومارجو
شكرا
على تلك الاعتمادات
هذه مجموعه رائعه من الوطني
بمناسبه بمناسبه الحديث عن الشعور الوطنيه
فقد يكون الفضل في وجود هؤلاء الوطنيين
الامهاتهم
و جيمس كروم ايضا الذي جاء من اسره مرموقه
وتوجه الى اماكن عده
ويحظى بشعبيه كبيره
حيث عمل مفوضا في الخدمه العامه
وهذه الولايه هي الاولى التي قد قدمت
اعتمادها لي وعلى راسها بابا بابا
يروح لي معطفك
اود ان اشكر ايضا
هذا ذلك الشخص القوي الذي يحب تلك الولايه
السنه
على مر سنوات السبعه الماضيه كنا
نعمل دون كلل من اجل انقاذ بلادنا في في
وجه اولئك الذين يكرهونها ويودونها
تدميرها فهذه القوه هي اقوى من الصين
واقوى من روسيا
وكوريا الشماليه وايران فكروا بذلك
هذه القوى من الداخل لان القياده اليمنيه
في امريكا اذا ما كانت موجوده فلن فما
كانت هذه الامه التي تواجه اي مشاكل فنحن
لم نواجه مشاكل مع روسيا اوكرانيا او
الصين التي تبدو بانها بصدد فعل شيء ما
وما من احد يتحدث عن الامر والان
يضعون في اكثر موقع خطر في تاريخ بلادنا
بسبب نوع الاسلحه التي تتحدث عنها فنحن
سوف نقف
في مواجهه الماركسيه ومواجهه
[تصفيق]
الديناصورات
لانه ما من احد قد يعلم اين مصدرها هو
اصلها لكن لابد لنا ان تصدى لهؤلاء
الشيوعيين ولهؤلاء المتطرفين البيئيين
وسوف نقف ايضا مع مساله حقوق حقوقنا في
مساله الحدود
وسوف نقف في مواجهه
المدعين العامين وفي كل مره اتلقى طلب
للمثول امام المحكمه
وسوف نقف في وجهي وسائل الاعلام التي تبث
اخبارا زائفه
وفي الخامس من نوفمبر عام 2024 سوف سوف
نقف في وجه المؤسسه
الفاسده وسوف نقوم
بالوقوف امام الرئيس جو بايدن الفاسد وسوف
نقوم بانهاء العمل الذي بدانا به
وحققنا نجاحا ابانا رئاسته
[تصفيق]
واعتقد ان الجميع
يدركوا ما الذي يحدث لكنني لن استسلم
ولن اتوقف ولن اتوقف عن عمليه القتال
[موسيقى]
احدهم يقولون البعض يتساءل اذا ما كنت سوف
اتقدم
لسبق الرئاسيه اقول نعم سوف اجعل امريكا
عظيمه مجددا لكن تمت امور سيئه تجري فيما
يتعلق بالانتخابات لكننا سوف نجعل البلاد
عظيمه كما لم نشهدها من قبل هل سوف تعملون
على انتشار بلادنا من هذه المجموعه
الفاشيه لجعل البلاد عظيمه مجددا
[تصفيق]
منذ البدايه
كنا نشهد ما نعيشه من تهديد وجودي في
بلادنا
فيما يتعلق بالمخاطر المتناميه ومسائل
الحدود
وتبديد كنوزنا وثرواتنا على حروب اجنبيه
على حروب الخارجيه لا تنتهي وعقاق
وطالما تساءل البعض بانه لم لن يتم انتخاب
بسبب عدم تاييد لتلك الاجنده
لكنني انا بكل صراحه لا اود من الشعوب ان
تحارب
فهذه المره الاولى منذ 70 عاما التي بدانا
بها حروبك وقمنا بهزيمه داعش والخلافه مئه
في المئه حققنا انجازات كبيره وقمنا
باعاده بناء القوات العسكريه واعطينا
ولا يمكن للمراه ان يصدق ما الذي حدث في
افغانستان التي باتت اكثر مصدرا للسلاح
الذي اعطيناهم اياه فهم يقوم فقد فقدنا
اعدادا كبيره من الجنود
وتخلفنا عن الركب في انتشال مجموعه كبيره
من
القوات الامريكيه
وقاموا باطلاق اكثر من قذيفه هوك من اجل
وقفنا هناك
وهذا امر يصعب تصديقه لقد لجاوا الى كافه
الاكاذيب والالاعيب وتحدثوا عن التدخل في
الانتخابات وفعلوا قصار جهدهم
من الذي كان يرسم لهم هذه السياسه التي
تسمح
بالتسلل عبر الحدود دون اي هويه افكروا
فيما حدث بحملته هل لكم تتخيلوا عكس ما
قدمته في حمله وحاربتهم من اجله وقد
زوروا الادله الحقيقيه والاف قدما مليون
دولار من اجل الحصول على ملف كتب من قبل
جاسوسا اجنبي من اجل توريطي بتهمه الخيانه
هؤلاء الناس لن يتوقفون عن عاداتهم وعن
شرورهم لابد من وقفهم لقد وضعوا بلادنا
على مسار الجحيم ويعلم ان كل ما كانوا
يقدمون عليه هو مجرد اكاذيب باطله تذكروا
ان الامر لا ليس
يتعلق بشخصيه الذين يرغبون بالملاحقته
لو كان اي شخص اخر لما كانت استطاع تحمل
كل ذلك
فاي شخص محافظ جمهوريز سوف ايضا ينالون
منه ولانهم يسعون لتدمير البلاد هذا السبب
الحقيقي لكنني اعلم الكثير وحتى في بعض
المرات كان البعض يقول لي كيف تتحمل هذه
الطريقه فاقول لهم لابد من محاربتهم
ومواجهتهم بطريقه لم يشدوها من قبل فكروا
في هذا الامر
لطالما سمعنا عن روسيا روسيا روسيا في
السابق
وتبين انها كلها ان كلها اكاذيب وملفاتي
الحزب الديمقراطي مثل وغيرهم لم
ينبس احد ببنت الشفا
فيما يتعلق بتلك الملفات وتبين بعد عامين
ونصف العام انه ما من تامر ومن ثم محاولات
العزل الاولى والثانيه والرقابه ولا توجد
في نفس الوقت رقابه على محتوى
جهاز اللابتوب الخاص
ابني بايدن
وسمعنا بعد ذلك عن الحملات المضلله
الروسيه التي باتت فضيحه كبيره
وسمحت لعدد كبيره من الناخبين الموجودين
معنا هنا اليوم الذين قالوا لا يمكننا ان
نصدق ذلك فكان هناك فوارق بنسبه
بنسبه كبيره لكن عملاء المجتمعات
الاستخبارتيه كذب والان يستخدمون نفس
الاكاذيب ونفسي رجالي الاف بي اي الفاسدين
والنائب العام وكذلك النواب العامين على
مستوى الولايات الذين تحدثوا عن التدخل في
الانتخابات
التي عاشتها بلادنا فهم يقومون
بانطلاقا من هذا الفساد هؤلاء المجرمون لا
يمكن مكافاتهم بل يجبوا هزيمتهم
لا يطاردونني بل سوف يسعون
لملاحقتكم وانا سوف اقف في طريقهم بكل
تاكيد
[تصفيق]
شكرا جزيلا
الاتهامات السخيفه والخليه من اي ادله من
قبل اداره في وزاره العدل سوف
سوف سوف
تذهب مهب الريح حالها حال الاتهامات
السابق فهذه مجرد ضرب من تضليل للعداله
وعرقلتها فكروا في بايدن بايدن يحاول ان
يزجه بالسجن بخصمه
الوطني كما كما فعل
شهد التاريخ بمقامه في روسيا منذ ثلاث
سنوات كنا بلد مستقل في مجال الطاقه ولا
نعاني من تضخم وكانت ضرائبنا منخفضه
بارتفاعا في اسعار الفوائد اعظم اقتصادا
في التاريخ فكروا في الامر استطيع ان اقف
طوال اليوم هذا لاتحدث عن الانجازات
العظيمه التي حققنا والان تسير الامور
باتجاه الخاطئ
التضخم بدا بالارتفاعات غير مسبوقه بدنا
نستورد الطاقه
من فنزويلا هل تصدقون ذلك ما من شخص عاقل
ليتخيل هذا الامر اما بالنسبه
لمساله الاتهامات فهي مساله مروعه لهذه
البلاد الامر
الجيد هو انه قد رفع من نسبه شعبيه
واستطلعت الراي الى درجه كبيره
لقد ارتفعت نسبه هذه النسبه واحد يتحدث عن
ان جمع الاموال عمل قد بدات اكبر سوف نكسب
بمستويات كبيره وسوف نتخلص من جو بايدن
في
هذه الجهود
لا اعلم اذا ما كنتم اخسروا في هذه هي
الاتهامات الموجهه الى ما كانت
نسبه التاييد في ذلك بهذا الحدود لكنهم
يرغبون
بتحقيق
مع ربهم لكننا مع ذلك استطعنا في
الانتخابات ان نحقق فوزا صارخا في عدد
الاصوات فقد حققنا انتخابات شهدت اكبر عدد
من التصويت في تاريخ البلاد
وهذا الامر سوف نراه ايضا قواتهم
الفيدراليه يجب ان لا تكون جزءا من هذه
المشكله لكنها قد تورطت بها ونحن لن نسمح
بحدوث ذلك لقد
انخرطت بذلك عبر تويتر وعبر فيسبوك
وقد تقول بانه قد يكون هناك
الفارق في تلك النسب التصويت بنسبه 17.5
وعندما كنا نعقد اجتماعاتنا فكنا نتوجه
الى جوريا حيث
فكان هناك بعض الاشخاص الذين لم يستطيعوا
تعبئه البطاقات الانتخابيه
وحتى ان نفذنا في الاباما بارقام قياسيه
وفي نفس الشيء وهؤلاء الاشخاص الذين
يديرون الانتخابات قالوا بانه غير ممكن ان
تفوز بالابااما وفي
ساوثكارولاينر وخساره في جورجيا بنسبه
ضئيله لابد ان ننتبه لما حصل
وكافه المستندات كانت
ضمن ما يعرف بقانون
بالقانون المستندات الرئاسه وهذا لا يمكن
ان يكون غير قانوني
ولكن ما من احد ليتحدث عن المستندات التي
كانت بحوزه
لانهم كانوا يرغبون بذلك من تطبيق ما يعرف
بقانون التجسس
فيتحدثون عن وجود صندوق مليء من
بالمستندات قانون
التجسس كان قد تم سنه في عام
ابان الحرب العالميه الاولى
وحتى لديه صناديق تحتوي على مستندات في
تشاينا تاون
الموجوده في واشنطن
ويقولون ان ترامب يقوموا بعرقله العداله
ومسارها
فقلت ليله الامس
ان بلادنا
تتمزق بسبب ما يحدث فلن يعد لدينا سوى
انتخابات مزيفه وحدود غير محكمه وتضخم
واقتصاد سيد لم نشد امرا من هذا بتاريخ
بلادنا وحاله انشقاق والانقسام باتت كبيره
وهذا امر سيء وشعبنا غاضب
وهم مستمرون بفعل ذلك واحيانا
بحاجه لاضرابات
واحداث تغيير لانه لا يمكننا ان نلقي
البلاد على هذا الحال تذكروا باننا اعتدت
ان اناصر هذا الامر وقلت بانه لا يمكننا
ان نعيش
في مقاله اليه الامور وسوف اغير حمله اسم
الحمله
لابقائها كما كانت
وهدفها ان نجعل امريكا عظيمه
وهي سوف تنافس
اختصارا للجمله
بالاحترام في العالم
بالمقارنه بالمكان التي كنا نتمتع بها في
السابق وما من احد يتحدث
عن عن
قضيه
التي سمحت لهم انذاك بالاحتفاظ بسجلاتهم
ومستنداتهم وكذلك كان القانون اسد عندما
انتهت فتره رئاستي كان هناك مجموعه من
الصناديق المليئه بالمستندات والكل يقوم
بالتقاط صور لها
حتى ان اناسا كانوا ينتظرون لتحميل تلك
الصناديق
عبر الشاحنات لكنها بكل صراحه كانت موجوده
خارج مبنى البيت الابيض بعد ان انتظرت
لفتره طويله وبعدها
جعلوا من الامر
اشبهه بعمليه التجسس
لم يكن عملنا جيد ان فما
لا يعقل ان تبقى هذه الصناديق خارج المبنى
خارج المبنى الابيض
فهذه المستندات هي مستندات ارشيفيه وبعد
ذلك تم مداهمه منزلي من قبل بعض وكلاء
الاف بي اي
يعني مره اخرى
يوجد لبيض
مجموعه كبيره من المستندات منذ عمل نائبا
للرئيس وحتى عندما كان
فالسنه لا يحق له ان يستحوذ على مستندات
سريه
لكنه
لم
لا يمكننا ان نصدق ان بايدن ايضا استحوذ
على مستندات سريه عندما
كان سيناتور
وفي اماكن لا يمكن
توقعها لكن فكروا
كان كان بحوزته اكثر من
1850 صندوق مليء بالمستندات
وكانت تدفع له
اموال كبيره من قبل الصين
بالاحتفاظ بهذه المستندات ومع ذلك يتقاضى
مليون دولار من قبل الصين
[موسيقى]
وفي حتى في مخزنه الخاص الذي يضم سياره
فهناك بعض المستندات السريه حيث لا توجد
اي اي خدمات امنيه اما في مارلاجو فهي
مدججه برجال الامن والحمايه
هذا يذكرنا بتاريخ البناء الذي
حظي به وحتى قال بانه قد يكون مكلفا ان
يتم السكن بهذا القصر الجميل من قبل شخص
مثله
لا لكنه
بالقسم الجنوبي من البيت الابيض
[موسيقى]
لكن
كانت لدي السلطه في الاحتفاظ بهذه
المسندات غير السريه بالمقارنه مع بايدن
لكن ما من شيء حدث له
رغمك كل تلك المرات التي حدثت فيها
تلك الوقائع
وكافه الرؤساء الامريكيين يفترض بهم اعاده
المستندات حتى في الاوقات المعاصره اذا ما
نظرتم الى هلال كلينتون التي قامت
بوضع سيرفر خاصم بها منتهكه كافه قوانين
الخصوصيه الامر الذي
كشف
[موسيقى]
الجوانب الماليه وعرضت بعض المعلومات
الحساسه وبعضها قد تم تسربه الى انتوني
وجلها توجه الى انثوينا وانا لست متاكدا
ما الذي حدث انذاك
وما الذي حدث الى كمبيوتر هانتر بايدن
وعندما قامت
كلينتون بحذف كافه تلك الايميلات الخاصه
بها التي فضح جزء منها
وتدمير الهواتف الايفون بالمطرقه
لكن
الحزب قام بحمايتها ولم يفعلوا اي شيء
بالتعاون مع الاف بي اي
ولم يقوموا باستدعائها للمثولي امام
المحكمه ولم يعقدوا جلسه هيئه محلفين
وقيل
بانه ما من اسباب تدفع لمقاضاته رغم انها
سربت اكثر من 32 الف ايميل ولم يتم توجيه
اتهم اليها كان يجلب اتهامها انذاك لكن مع
ذلك هذا الامر لم يحدث بل تمت حمايتها من
قبل
الديمقراطين وبايدن ايضا
لم يتم لم تتم ادانته على ما فعله
وكنت مندهشا لان احدهم قام باعاده تلك
الصناديق
الى لانهم كلهم فعلوا هذا الامر فكانوا
يضعون هذه الصناديق عبر الرفوف يلتقطون
صورا وبعد ذلك كانوا يعتذرون بعد التقاط
تلك صور شهيره لكن هذه صناديق
قد ظهرت عبر الصحف
عبر اماكن مختلفه لكن ما من احد لي يتحدث
عنها فقط دون الترانس الذي
ومن ثم من تهمه واحده تتحول الى ثمان
وثلاثين تهمه كما تم سوقها على قنوات
التلفزه
هذا الامر لم نراه فقط بدانا بتهمه
وتوصلنا الى سبعه او الى 38 تهمه هذه
عمليه ملاحقه سياسيه
تتم من خلالها معامله الحزب الجمهوريه
الحزب الجمهوري بطريقه متعمده ومن قبل
الحزب الديمقراطي
والان
فكروا معي
يبدو بانه بريء
لكنه في نفس الوقت هو الذي تسبب في
الكوارث التي حدثت في هذه البلاد منذ
سنوات طويله فكان يقوم بتعقب
المسيحيين المتشددين
وهو
كنت قد
رقبته كيف تحدث يوم الامس لمده دقيقتين
وكان خائفا لانهم هم بصراحه
مجموعه من الجبناء
وهو لا يعمل الا على نشر
تلك
التهم المرفقات ولا يجدر به فعل ذلك
بالمقارنه مع بايدن الذي يحتوي على
مستندات سريه لكن مع من خاطب بذلك
ويسعى لاخفائها عنهم هذه عرقله ايضا
لكن نحن لم نقم بعرقله العداله هذه
مساله
تنم عن حاله مرضيه لدى هؤلاء الناس الذين
يجبوا التخلص منهم
[تصفيق]
والان
لدينا سابقتين في
في القضاء في بلادنا حيث نجد الديمقراطين
الذين يرغبون بحمايه المجرمين
[موسيقى]
فما جرى في اتلانتا امر مروع ما دفع الناس
للخوف من الخروج
وبالمقارنه مع
ما كنت اقوم به
وهيلري لم تعد مهمه
ففي التاريخ لم نشهد اي شخص فاسد بنفسي
ما نراه اليوم
وحتى بوجود تلك اللجن التي تعمل مثل
وبوجود اعضاء مثل جميل
التي ترغب بالحصول على ملايين من
الدولارات
من اجل السماح لبعض شركات الطاقه بالعمل
في الخارج وهذا امرؤسف ليست مصادفه انهم
قد وجهوا الاتهام لي بنفس اليوم الذي تبين
فيه ان ان الاف بي اي قد حصل على ادله
دامه بتلقي بايدن
بتلقي نجله بايدن باموال لاموال من
اوكرانيا
لقد ماتت اوكرانيا
مجموعه من الدخائر الكبيره التي كانت هي
محور القضيه والان نحن
بحاجه لحمايه انفسنا وقد تلقى اموالا
طائله من اوكرانيا
وبالمناسبه في هذه الحرب لو كنت موجوده
لنا لفاوضت الحل عليها وتوصلت الى حل
مباشره خلال 24 ساعه بينزلنسكي وبوتين
لكنت قد انجزت هذه المهمه في غضون يوم
واحد
في
حاله لسانه بانه فلسعى للنيل من ترامب
ويسعون لانهم انهم كانوا عادلين مع هنتر
بايدن
في حين انهم تجاهلوا الرشا وغسل الاموال
والجرائم الاخرى التي كان يتم اقترافها
دون تجريمه
وباتت لدينا مجموعه كبيره من النواب العام
الذين
لا يعدون منصفين ولديهم ميول جنونيه
ويسعون للزج في
هذه الاتهامات وتحدثوا كثيرا عن نتائج
الاتهامات في السابق وهذا امر سخيف
[تصفيق]
واذا ما نظرتم الى الارقام
التي
تحكم وبنفسها وتتحدث بنفسها عن نفسها
وعندما تنظرون الى الاشياء اخرى في صناديق
الاقتراع هو بعض البيانات التي ظهرت من
هذه الانتخابات في العام 2020
فنحن كان لدينا مسافه لنقطعها طويله في
جوجل كان لدي الحق لاشتكي اذا ما كانت
الانتخابات في جورجيا وفقا لراي
عظيمه لكن حقيقه انها كانت كارثيه
[تصفيق]
ادينا بهذا القدر من كلمه الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب في جورجيا طبعا هذا
ياتي في اطار حملته الانتخابيه رغم كل
الدعاء والقضائيه المرفوعه ضده وكان اخرها
طبعا قضيه الوثائق السريه للبيت الابيض
ابرز ما جاء فيه اعداء امريكا بالداخل
يشكلون خطرا اكبر من الاعداء في الخارج
ترامب قال غياب القياده الحقيقيه عن
امريكا سببا لمشاكلنا مع روسيا والصين كما
قال ساقف في 20 24 امام الاداره الامريكيه
الحاليه الفاسده ولن استسلم ولن اتوقف عن
القتال لاجل امريكا قال بان تهم الموجهه
لن تمنعني من الترشح للرئاسه وساعود
للرئاسه وساجعل امريكا عظيما كما سنواجه
الغش والتزوير في الانت المقبله نعود
لنستمع ايضا لكلمه الرئيس ترامب
بنسبه 37 في المئه اما هو فقط حصل على امل
شخص المنافس الاخر حصل على 51%
لم يكن يخسر بقدر كبير في يوم الانتخابات
هذا جاء مخالفا لتوقعات الجميع
لابد من وجود انتخابات النزيهه
فلا توجد بلد ولا توجد حكومه
يمكنها ان تشهد مثل ذلك الحدث
لطالما اتحدث عن
قصص مختلقه
[موسيقى]
وتبين لديهم ان جورجيا هي واحده من
الولايات التي هبت
كانت فيه الاشرطه المسجله
عمليه التصويت
عن طريق البريد
لكن مع ذلك
فان النائب العام هناك قد بددد كافه جهوده
في محاوله منه للسعي مني
والنيل مني
واحدهم يرى بانها باتت تلك بان اتلانتها
هي واحده من الولايات التي باتت محفوفه
بالمخاطر فهناك جرائم ومخدرات واناس
يغادرونها بكميات كبيره وهناك مجرمون
لكن ما من احد يتحدث عن هذا الامر
لديهم مجرمون لا احد يعيرهم اي اهميه
اعدادهم بارتفاع
انه امر مروع
الامر المثير للاهتمام حول الشعب هو انهم
كانوا رائعين لكن لا بد لي ان اشتكي على
تلك الانتخابات
كانت موجوده معنا وهي اظن انها بيننا
اليوم
ها هي
[تصفيق]
كمان
ترغبين بادلاء بعض الكلمات تفضلي
اود منكم ان تعلموا ان هذه مساله انا على
درايه بها ان الرئيس ترامب كان قد تغلب
على جو بايدن في عمليات التصويت والاقتراع
تلو الاخرى وقد نال السبع نقاط
واذا مات واذا ما ترشح في مواجهه كمال لها
فسوف يتوافق عليها ب 11% دعونا يا اهالي
جورجيا
ننجز عملنا في عام 2024 لنعيد الرئيس
ترامب الى البيت الابيض لاربع سنوات اخرى
كنت اتمنى ان تكوني اكل اكثر عدائيه انها
انسانه عظيمه تحب ولايتها تحب اقليمها تحب
الامه
في السنوات الثلاثه الماضيه تتذكرون
كنت اشتكي بشان الانتخابات
لكن كما تعلمون عندما تحدثت عن الهاتف
فكان لدي مجموعه من المحامين
في تلك الولايات كانوا يستمعون وقالوا ان
هناك اناس كثر يستمعون الى هذه المكالمه
لكن ما هو المقصود بذلك
تبين فيما بعد باننا تحدثنا سويه وحول
كيفيه نظره لتلك الانتخابات
مع فريق متكامل من المحاميين والمكالمه
كان جيده لكن احد هؤلاء المحامين وهو
محامي ولايه
قال لي سيدي ما قلته غير ملائم لا بد لك
ان تسحب ما صرحت به لا يمكننا ان نمضي
بهذا الامر ما لم تسحب الكلام المروع الذي
تفوه به سوف نقوم باتهامك على ما ذكرته
قلت كلا فقد تحدثنا
وفي اليوم التالي كانوا يدركون
[موسيقى]
ما حدث في الانتخابات فمثلا بعد اذا ما
حدث بعض بعد بعد بضعه اشهر وجودي مجموعه
من اعضاء الكونغرس الذين قالوا
بان كل
هذه الاحداث
سوف تدون
لكن ما من احد ليشتكي
على ما تم في تلك المحادثه الهاتفيه
لكنه اكرر ذلك الشخص انه لماذا ادلب بهذا
التصريح
لم يستطيعوا تحمل الامر لو سمعوا ثم تخاطب
لكان لديهم التزام بابلاغها عبر الهاتف
مباشره هل انت مستمعتهم الى الشريط
واستمعتم الى المحادثه لكن ما منخطب وما
من شيء خطا قلته كنت اشتكي عن الانتخابات
التي اعتقد انها كانت زائفه وفي اليوم
الذي لا يسمح لك ان تشتكي به الى السلطات
العامه او ان تشتكي عن الانتخابات فنحن
بتنا
بلاد اشبهوا بالصين الشيوعيه
تذكروا ذلك الامر
فهناك مجموعه من
الصحفيين الذين ينقلون الاخبار الكاذبه
فهي لم تشتكي بالتالي على تلك الاشياء
المروعه وعلى هذا الحديث الذي دار عبر
الهاتف
لكنهم محترفون ويسقنون اسرار مهنتهم
فهم محامون
كانوا كانوا يجروا بهم ان يتفوهوا
ويتحدثوا مباشره عن حقيقه هذا الامر لكن
اعداد كبيره من هؤلاء المحاميين لم يذكروا
هذا الامر اما الان
وهذه الولايه تعيش اعلى نسب من الجريمه من
على صعيد عمليات القتل التي تتم هناك
اما الان فهم
تركوا كافه مشاغلهم وركزوا على تلك
المكالمه الهاتفيه
للاسف ارتفعت نسبه
عمليات القتل بواحد وسبعين في المئه
والان يتناسون كل هذا الامر وجل همهم هو
ان يعملوا على اضطهاد
ومقاضات الجمهوريين ممثلين ترامب
وهذا لا يختلف ايضا عن ما قام به عناب
العام في منهات نيويورك
حيث قدمت لائحه التهم انذاكر كانت ضرب من
السخافه اذ لم يكن هناك اي جريمه
وقاموا
وقاموا بانفاق 200 مليون دولار على تلك
المقادات ولم يتوصلوا الى اي جريمه
وقالوا بانهم يرغبون بالنيل مني والاطاحه
احدى هؤلاء النواب
تحدثت بانها ترغب بالنيل مني وسوف تعمل
على الاطاحه
بي كانوا قد دفعوا ملايين الدولارات من
اموال الضرائب من اجل هذا الغرض
هؤلاء مجموعه من المرضى وكالاتي انفاذ
القانون باتت اداه بيدي
تلك
بيدي الحزب
الديمقراطيه علينا ان نختار اما دوله
عميقه او الديمقراطيه والان نحن نتوجه الى
الدوله العميقه
والتي
تتسم بالشيوعيه
والماركسيه رغم ان مصطلح الدوله العميقه
قد يبدو مناسبا للاسف باتت بلادنا فاشله
وبصرف النظر اذا ما هم كسبوا او نحن او
نحن فزنا
فمثلا عندما انظر الى اتلانتا
وما جرى هناك على مر فتره قصيره من الزمن
على صعيد السلامه فهذا امر مخيف فالناس
وكافه المدن التي يحكمها الديمقراطيون
احدى المدن العظيمه في العالم التي باتت
مضطربه في نهايه اليوم
اما
الشيوعيون الذين سوف يفوزون لتدمير البلاد
او نحن سوف نقوم بالحاق الهزيمه
بالشيوعيين هذا قد نسميهم بالقاب مختلفه
فشين ماركسيين
يعملون على اضطهاد حركاتنا
من الجنون وعدونا يدرك ذلك
فهم يعرفون باننا نحن فقط الذين سوف نكون
قادرين على وقفهم
وراينا الغش الذي ارتكبوا
وقلت لكم باننا عشنا انتخابات عظيمه في
عام 2016 وحتى في عام 2020 لكنه وسائل
الاعلام لم ترغب بنقل كافه الحقائق فهناك
الملايين من الاصوات التي لم يتموا
احصائها
لو اعدتم
لو اعتموني الى البيت الابيض فسوف نصبح
امه حره مجددا
[تصفيق]
شكرا
اليوم بصفه المرشح الوحيد
الذي لديه الكثير من الادوات
للتخلص من هذا النظام الفاسد فما من
شخص قد عمل بهذه الطريقه وسوف يفعلونه
النفس الشيء
ولكنهم سوف سوف يتساقطون ويتهمون
وسوف نقوم بتجفيف
هذا
هذه المنابع
التي تنم عن الفساد والمرض
وكما ارى من خلال استطلاعات الراي واحدا
تلو الاخر وحده تلو الاخرى فنحن
متفوقين باكثر من
34 نقطه
لا اعلم حقيقه
استطلاعات الراي تلك فتمت مقابله اعداد
كبيره من الناس فنحن
متفوقين بفرخ كبير من النقاط
[موسيقى]
ديسانتوس 13
ست نقاط وقد انخفضت
نقاطه رغم
انه يتجه لخوض حرب اخرى وترامب في سده
القياده
وفي كل استطاعات الراي التي جرت في 28
مليار دولار
للمزارعين من الصين فكروا في هذا الامر
فكروا في الامر اعطتنا الصين مليار دولار
بسبب السوء استخدامي المزارع هناك وقلت
بانه ما من طريقه بان سوف نخسر ايوا
اشياء حديثه اشياء غريبه تحدث في السياسه
فانت تقوم باعتماد وتاييد بعض الاشخاص
وسرعان ما ينقلبون عليه
وتعطيهم فرصه لكن
ان حياتهم المهنيه تكون على وشك
الانهيار وتعطيهم فرصه للنجاه وبعد ذلك
ينقلبون ضدك ويصبحون من ضمن الصفوف التي
ترغب بالانقلاب على اترمم هو في ايه
وكاننا نتفوق باثنين واربعين نقطه
وكذلك ايضا
نتفوق على
اعداد كبيره
وهذا ينطبق على ايضا استطلاعه الراي في
وسكانسن واريزانيا وجورجيا التي نتفوق
فيها عن بايدن بنسبه 5%
واستطلاعات الراي جديده من المؤسسات
الديمقراطيه تظهر بانني المرشح الوحيد
الذي يتراس
الذي يتقدم في
[موسيقى]
في
في اكثر من ولايه ولقد حققنا اكثر من اي
شخص كان يحسب ان هذا امرا ممكن منذ العام
2016 وعندما اعلنت عن استعداد للترشح في
عام 2005
كان الجميع يشعر بالاستغراب
لكنني لم الجا لتقاضي اموال طائله من
الصين كما فعل بعض الرؤساء
ومع ذلك استطعنا ان نقدم اكبر تخفيضا
للضرائب في تاريخ البلاد التي تضاهي ما
قدمه
صنعنا اعظم اقتصادا في العالم وحققنا
الاستقلاليه في مجال الطاقه
للمره الاولى في 64 عاما واسعار الغاز
كانت بواقع واحد فاصل 70
للقانون الواحد
اتحولت وانقلبت الايه يرغبون باعطائكم
سياره كهربائيه لتنتظر اربع ساعات في صفوف
من اجل شحنها
منذ
اعتلائي السلطه وفي اليوم الاول سوف اعمل
على انهاء كل هذه الامور وحلها اذا كنتم
ترغبون بالحصول على مركبات اخرى لفتره
طويله قد يكونوا هذا امر مناسب خيركم واذا
ما كنتم ترغبون ايضا بالحصول على سياره
تسير بالغاز فهذا خير اخر
واذا كنتم ترغبون بالحصول على غساله
تسمح بها خروج المياه
وقد فعلت هذا الامر
جاء البعض من اهالي اوهايو لمقابلته
لا يقلون قدرا عن عظمتكم
وكنا ان نرى كيف تقوم الصين
وكوريا بالعمل على
الغسالات بمثابه مكبات يتم
التخلص منها
كانوا يبيعون تلك الغسالات باسعار باسعار
زهيده
لكن سرعان ما تضاعفت الاسعار
بثلاثه اضعاف لا استطيع ان اصدق كيف نعيش
في ظل كل هذه التغيرات لقد اسسنا اكثر
حدود امنه في تاريخ البلاد هذه الحدود
التي تمتد الى الاف من الاميال
ودفعنا مكسيكو
لتقديم تسهيلات لنا
والرئيس المكسيكي هو صديق مقرب له
وقلت له بانه لابد لكم ان تخصصوا ثمانيه
وعشرين الف جنديه على الحدود هناك
لكن احد الممثلين عن رئيس
باننا كنا نسعى لتامين مثل هذا الامر منذ
عقدين من الزمن
لدى اجتمعت مع
الرئيس المكسيكي
وعملنا على رسم سياسه يتم من خلالها
الجلوس
بحيث يمكن ان يستتب الامن
لكن عندما سمعت رفضا في
منه على هذا المقترح
كان ردي بانني سوف اضع وتعرف دخول بواقع
خمسه وعشرين دولار على كل شخص لكن سرعنا
ما تمت الموافقه
بعد يومين عبر مكالمه هاتفيه
واتصل
مع صديقا لي بالمناسبه
[موسيقى]
وسرعان ما سمعت القبول منه وقال انه من
دواعي
سروري ويشرفني ان
اعمل على نشر 28 الف جندي مكسيكي الامر
الذي سوف يوقف الاتجار بالبشر والنساء على
وجه التحديد والمخدرات
هذه الجرائم التي ترتكب عبر الانترنت لكن
استطعنا ان نوقف هذا الامر
وانخفضت نسبه المخدرات اما الان فقد
ارتفعت مجددا بواقع 11% فهي
تدخل الى البلاد بكميه كبيره
ومن ثم اوقفنا سياسه
الاعتقال ومن ثم الافراج عن هؤلاء
المجرمين تخيلوا هذه السياسه انكم تقومون
باعتقال مجرم قد يكون هو الاسوا بحياته
ومن ثم نقوم باطلاق السراحه ما هذه
السياسه السخيفه
كندا والمصيفه كانوا والان يرغبون باعاده
التفاوض مع عباده بايدن وذكرت لهؤلاء
الذين يستمعون
الان واخوهم لا تفعلوا ذلك فقد استغلون
لسنوات طويله والان نحن لدينا اتفاق الذي
يعد افضل لنا
فاياكم واعاده مفاوضه ذلك الاتفاق
لان تلك البلاد لطالما عكفت على سرقتنا
ونهبنا
باستمرار لان ابرام هذه الاتفاقيات الصعبه
لا يمكن قبولها لقد وقفت بوجه الصين
بطريقه لم يتعرض لها اي رئيس امريكي سابق
هؤلاء الذين كانوا يقوم
يتهربون من الضرائب واستطعت ان احصل على
اموال طائله الى الخزانه الامريكيه من
الصين في حين ان اي رئيس لم يحقق اي سن
ووزير الزراعه سنه
[موسيقى]
وبفضله تم التفاوض على تعزيز
المنتجات الزراعيه الخاصه بالمزارعين مما
در ملايين الدولارات على الخزانه
الامريكيه وكذلك عملنا على
تعيين قادم في المحكمه العليا
وقمنا ببناء القوات العسكريه لدينا مخزون
من الذخيره اكثر من اي وقت مضى
وقمت ايضا بوضع الحظر حظر بالسفر على بعض
الجهادين الاسلاميين المتطرفين
وكنت قد تعرضت الانتقادات شديده على هذا
التوجهات
وكانوا يقولون لي فل تسمح لهم بالدخول لكن
كان سؤالي لماذا اذا ما نظرتم الى تلك
السنوات الاربع ما الذي حققناه على
الجبهات كهف كامله لقد حققنا
انجازات كثيره وتخيل ما الذي نستطيع ان
نحققه خلال السنوات الاربعه المقبله سوف
نجعل بلادنا اكثر عظمه مما كانت عليه في
السابق
[تصفيق]
جمله من العوائق التي اعترضتنا
على وهي خمسه عشر مليون شخص بين السكان من
السجون
والمصححات العقليه يعني تقريبا ساعه من
الوقت
السابق دونالد ترامب في جورجيا تحدث عن
الكثير من المواضيع وخاصه عن الاتهامات
التي وجهت اليه لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات